[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 23 avril bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez pour cette nouvelle
édition spéciale sur tv 78
le point pour commencer sur la
propagation du pot vide 19 dans les
yvelines hier mercredi 378 personnes
avaient succombé dans les hôpitaux du
département ce qui représente 7 décès
supplémentaires en 24 heures le nombre
d'hospitalisations a légèrement
réaugmenter s'établissant désormais à
892 cent trente et une personnes était
en réanimation hier soit 5 de moins en
24 heures et depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire une donnée positive 1208
le nombre d'ivg les noirs venus à
domicile suite à une amélioration de
leur état de santé
les ai pas de vous le savez sont
grandement touchés par le virus avec des
résidents et personnels concernés et pas
forcément testé en conséquence avec l
agence régionale de santé
le département des yvelines lance une
campagne de dépistage au sein des 90
maisons de retraite du territoire elle
s'adresse en priorité aux établissements
n'ayant pas eu l'occasion de tester leur
seigneur et professionnel pour
constituer leur équipe médicale vingt
personnes ont été recrutées une action
dans le cadre du plan d'urgence et de
maintien des activités votée en
assemblée départementale vendredi
dernier justement c'est dans le cadre de
ce plan que les yvelines déploie
également des tablettes dans les ehpad
via l'opérateur public
interdépartemental la seine et yvelines
numériques est 200 appareils seront
ainsi distribués sur le territoire pour
permettre aux personnes âgées et de
garder le lien avec leurs proches à
distance est la première remise a eu
lieu ce matin elle s'est déroulée à
l'ehpad et de la source à viroflay en
présence de pierre bédier le président
de la collectivité
une opération à d'un montant total de
400 mille euros c'est les yvelines
numériques à à distribuer également en
15 tablette à la maison de l'enfance des
yvelines située à mantes la jolie
l objectif en plus du renforcement du
lien social et celui de la continuité
pédagogique
le reportage d'aurélie ronzet de patrick
jacques de dixmude dans ce carton 15
tablettes numériques seront bientôt
transmises aux enfants accueillis au
sein de la maison de l'enfance des
yvelines elles sont fournies par seine
et yvelines numériques premier opérateur
public interdépartemental
on gère donc pour le compte du
département visé
des collèges et
l'ensemble de l'équipement en tablettes
des collégiens et donc nous avions un
stock prévu pour l'année prochaine et on
a décidé de libérer ce stock des
tablettes à destination d'enfants de 3 à
12 ans confie à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
elles ont un double objectif garder un
contact visuel avec leurs parents et
assurer la continuité pédagogique en ce
temps de confinement j'étais plutôt vos
satisfaite de voir arriver de l'aide de
l'aide pour les enfants effectivement à
suivre leur scolarité mais aussi pour
mes éducateurs les éducateurs de la
maison de l'enfance qui doivent
s'adapter tellement à la situation
d'enfants la scolarité le niveau d
scolarité adaptée aussi pour un certain
nombre d'enfants tout est sécurisé mais
vraiment et on a accès à des
applications qui sont validées par
l'éducation nationale n'avait qu'un
ordinateur pour tous les enfants donc au
niveau de photocopier tous les papiers
qui avait pour tous les enfants
c'est vrai que c'était compliqué ça va
être beaucoup plus simple pour nous déjà
pour envoyer et puis pour eux ça va être
une façon aussi plus ludique de travail
et donc plus motivant au total 1200
tablettes numériques vont être
distribués par scène et vie numérique
dans les maisons de l'enfance et les
ehpad des deux départements
la procédure est ouvert depuis lundi la
campagne de déclaration des revenus de
2019 et actif pour un mois et demi un
dépôt de déclarations adapté en ces
temps de crise sanitaire le calendrier a
été rallongée lé centres de finances
publiques n'accueille pas de personnes
sur place à la télédéclaration est donc
à privilégier la procédure est aussi
simplifié avec la déclaration
automatique pour déclarer il suffit de
vérifier des informations pré remplie et
de les valider ou de les modifier voici
le calendrier
vous avez jusqu'au jeudi 11 juin pour
faire votre déclaration en ligne et
jusqu'au vendredi 12 juin pour déposer
votre déclaration papier ce dernier cas
de figure est valable uniquement si vous
avez être déclarer vos revenus en format
papier en 2019
38e jour de confinement une période qui
devrait durer jusqu'au lundi 11 mai avec
la réouverture ensuite progressive des
commerces
elle et restaurants ne sont pas pour
autant concernés aucun calendrier n'a
été communiquée pour l'heure pour éviter
les pertes alimentaires et financières
certains établissements mise donc sur la
vente à emporter c'est le cas de ce
restaurant à montigny le bretonneux le
reportage de mathilde aux milliers de
patrick jacques de dixmude
au menu ce midi pour ce vétérinaire qui
travaillent à deux pas ces repas
mauriciens au drive qui vient d'être
installé au restaurant lille où coco
super merci beaucoup
après quand je finirai de bosser parce
que c'est rigolo jusqu'à deux ans et
demi je venais souvent manger ici quand
j'avais pas le temps est l'alpha car aux
rabbins prononcer quand même très très
pratique
parce que
des fois on n'a pas le temps je voyais
l'ingénieur jean je devais avoir dix
minutes pour manger ça me permet d'avoir
quelque chose à proximité et en plus ce
qui est beau parce que c'est vrai que
c'est toujours bon ici après plusieurs
semaines de fermeture
impossible pour cette gérante de par
ouvrir son restaurant avant d'organiser
des ventes à emporter
elle ad'abord livrer des repas au
personnel soignant de l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien à trappes et dans
certains commissariats
quand je vois le le président a annoncé
que le confinement ce ballon j'ai
l'occasion je dis là c'est pas possible
il faudra que je fais quelque chose
parce que je veux vous dire une chose
c'est vrai dans la restauration
ça sort mais ça rend pas voilà le
problème c'est que il y a tout à payer
alors vous voyez le g10 là ça commence à
m'inquiéter
et là je dis oui je sais pas ce que j'ai
là l'essence pour le drive et c'est que
j'ai fait je dis je met en place le
drive pour essayer de combler les pertes
financières
la gérante est dans l'obligation
d'ouvrir son restaurant 7 jours sur 7
avec une carte réduite et un prix fixe
elle reçoit une trentaine de clients les
jours les plus influents je trouve que
dans la semaine c'est calme
et quand même je veux vous dire que je
fais si j'ai fait une dizaine de plats
bon ça paye sapm électricité s'appelle
hausse appel
les téléphones tout ce qui est l'objet
de jets pas de choix sinon mais on met
la clé sous la porte comme toutes mes
collègues comme on va dire le coiffeuse
qu'on va tout les gens qui les petits
commerces pas comme beaucoup de
restaurateurs et le design kia attend à
présent les nouvelles annonces de l'état
concernant la réouverture des commerces
compliqué aussi en cette période de
confinement de trouver un bureau de
poste ouvert pour envoyer un courrier ou
une carte à ses proches une entreprise
située à bois d'arcy propose de le faire
à votre place tout se passe en ligne sur
le site merci-facteur les détails de son
fondateur interrogé par aurélien ça peut
du coup les conviviales comme des cartes
illustrées
ça peut être des photos ça peut être
aussi des courriers administratifs des
recommandés etc
vous allez valider votre courrier en
ligne et nous le jour même on râle
imprimés et le poster depuis le début du
confinement on a environ une
multiplication par six de nos volumes
d'envoi on a eu au tout début du
confinement énormément de d'envoi de
professionnels qui se retrouvaient jour
au lendemain en télétravail qui était un
petit peu désemparé avec aussi beaucoup
de deux choses du point de vue
administratif à gérer en urgence donc on
a eu une énorme augmentation de volume
des professionnels au début du
confinement
ensuite ça s'est un peu stabilisé et par
contre le les envois de cartes des
particuliers lui se maintient un très
haut niveau
parce que les gens évidemment manque de
contact beau coup d'envoi aussi vers les
ehpad vers les verts des personnes âgées
et sert à ça on le constate vraiment une
très très forte hausse à ce niveau là
ce projet pourrait être prochainement
une sérieuse alternative à l'offre de
transports actuels dans la région le
collectif vélos ile de france qui
regroupe 30 associations a imaginé le
rer vers réseau express régional vélo
l'objectif relier les pistes cyclables
existantes pour en faire un tout
continue sécuritaire et confortable pour
l'usagé du vélo partout sur le
territoire est la région vient
d'annoncer son engagement à hauteur de
60 % du projet 300 millions d'euros
seront ainsi mobilisés pour le rer b
l'idée de prévoir une mise en oeuvre
anticipée du réseau pour proposer une
solution de déplacement sur dans le
cadre de la période de déconfinement
écouter le porte parole du collectif
vélos ile de france
chaque seconde à conthey nous sommes
vraiment pied d'oeuvre d'heure en heure
en fait la bonne nouvelle c'est que
hervé pour la région a été actée et là
on va le réaliser sous forme temporaire
on appelle ça d'ailleurs le ton pour
hervé et là il nous reste quelques jours
quelques semaines jusqu'au 11 mai où on
a encore la possibilité de mettre en
place de façon relativement facile parce
que le trafic motorisé a chuté de 90%
nous devons absolument mettre en place
une carte qui va très rapidement indiqué
à tous les habitants où ils peuvent se
déplacer en sécurité à vélo
si on a choisi avec avec nos
spécialistes et la région des
itinéraires qui vont le long des axes de
transports publics les plus attirés et
là je penserai horaire à b et d et aussi
la ligne 13 du métro et c'est donc là
surtout en priorité que nous allons
mettre en place des itinéraires
cyclables des pistes cyclables
temporaire pour permettre aux habitants
de découvrir leur chemin à vélo et de le
faire avec une distanciation sociales
appropriées
prochaine étape financer les 40 derniers
pourcents du projet le collectif espère
la mobilisation de la métropole du grand
paris et des départements
la crise sanitaire impact aussi le tissu
associatif avec un arrêt partielle voire
totale des activités des bénévoles qui
sont également en confinement à saint
quentin en yvelines qui recense 3200
associations sur le territoire le
service dédié reste actif via la
plateforme associations pointent sky
point fr elle recense toutes les
informations
riddick renseignements également
administrative des guides pratiques et
des vidéos et guide de survie pendant le
confinement mesures d'appui à l'activité
des formations en ligne et gratuité des
appels à projets sont également est
disponible sur la plateforme
et pourquoi ne pas profiter de ce
confinement pour créer votre junior
association c'est ce que propose à la
maison des jeunes et de la culture à l'
usine à chapeaux de rambouillet ce
dispositif national s'adresse aux jeunes
de 11 à 18 ans aurélie rond je vous en
parlais justement avec votre invité
nous sommes avec julie manar le bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes animatrice jeunesse et
relais départemental des juniors
associations nous sommes également avec
alexandra d'argent jordao bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes animateur social
chargé du développement à des juniors
associations alors vous travaillez au
sein de la mjc la maison des jeunes de
la culture de l'usiné à chapeaux à
rambouillet et dans le cadre de la
situation actuelle et bien vous avez
lancé le projet une junior association
pendant ton confinement alors bien sûr
un on va parler de ce projet dans
quelques minutes avant ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'est une
junior association alors junior
association c'est un dispositif national
qui permet à des jeunes de 11 à 18 ans
de se constituer en groupe et de
fonctionner comme une association loi
1901 donc avec des assurances et des
garanties qu'ils vont vraiment une
similaire aux associations déclarées en
préfecture
et c'est sur l'ensemble du territoire
diw notamment pour pour les yvelines oui
en fait c'est ça fonctionne sur
l'ensemble de la france
et après on est répartie donc en relais
départementaux et savoir que sur les
îles il n'y en a deux donc l usine à
chapeaux qui relais départemental sur la
partie rurale du territoire et la ligue
de l'enseignement qui va être les
départementales sur le reste en fait
alors julie maintenant quel type
d'association on retrouve alors nous
avons vraiment tout type d'association
et pour vous doit vous donner un petit
ordres didier ans
à peu près 70 % des juniors associations
qui sont créées pour oeuvrer dans le
milieu de l'animation locale que ce soit
de leur quartier de leur village de leur
groupe d'amis et puis on a à peu près
40% des gia qui sont axées sur le côté
culturel donc l'organisation
d'événements la création de pièces de
théâtre de comédie musicale
et puis en troisième position le set
cette troisième position concerne
vraiment tout ce qui va être séjours
spécifiques et organisations voilà deux
week-ends ou de ou de séjour c'est les
grands les les trois grands domaines qui
arrivant en haut du classement alors
alexandre vous vous intervenez notamment
sondé des établissements scolaires ans
oui c'est ça en fait c'est julie
vraiment qu'est relais départemental moi
mon rôle ça va plus etre de promouvoir
et de faire en sorte que le dispositif
puisse être développé
donc en intervenant dans les
établissements scolaires mais aussi dans
les structures jeunesse et dans tous les
lieux qui vont accueillir des jeunes
pour leur présenter le dispositif et
leur donner envie de s'engager et de
créer et de se rendre compte qu'en fait
il ya pas besoin d'attendre d'être
majeur pour pouvoir développer des
projets c'est vraiment un des objectifs
de junior association et c'est ce qu'on
essaie de leur montrer à travers l'un de
nos interventions
alors aujourd'hui vous accompagnez
combien de junior association une en a
12 je croise je dis pas de bêtises il y
en a deux qui viennent de nous rejoindre
il ya très peu de temps et on est super
contents parce que depuis le mois de
janvier ça a été ça a été assez
assez explosif en termes de junior
association qui se constitue et je veux
dire on peut rajouter effectivement une
dizaine qui est également accompagné par
la ligue de l'enseignement si on parle à
l'échelle du département entier alors
j'imagine qu'avec le confinement
forcément c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais vous avez quand même lancé
justement à un projet est ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter alexandre oui en
fait l'idée d'une et gia pendant ton
confinement c'était de voir que on avait
quand même un petit peu plus de temps
libre
a priori pendant ce confinement
puisqu'on était moins pris part toutes
les activités qu'on peut avoir au
quotidien et donc c'était peut-être
l'occasion pour les jeunes si de se
poser de prendre le temps de réfléchir à
ce qu'ils avaient envie de faire et puis
peut-être de constituer un dossier
puisque la première étape pour créer une
junior association c'est de remplir un
formulaire en ligne de réunir toute une
série de documents
donc en fait tout ce temps administratif
là c'est déjà quelque chose qui peut
être fait malgré le confinement et jeudi
vous avez notamment fait un facebook
live au début du mois justement pour
parler de ce projet exactement alors oui
alexandre nous a embarqués dans
ce projet qui était une première pour
moi mais effectivement c'était une
présentation plutôt plutôt ludique sur
la sur les ondes donc donc ça a bien
marché puisqu'on avec pas mal de pas mal
de vue une interaction puisque des
jeunes qui me posaient des questions en
direct non c'était c'était une chouette
expérience et vous allez revoir
peut-être je pense qu'alexandre oui oui
on espère pouvoir faire peut-être même
après le confinement parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que c'était un outil est un
format qui était quand même plutôt
plutôt chouette mais bon ça ça remplace
pas le contact humain bien évidemment
quoi qu'il en soit alors je suis une
dernière question j'allais dire la
question pratique si justement les
jeunes nous regarder et veulent se
lancer dans l'aventuré d'une junior
association comment ça se passe et un
site internet d'imaginer exactement
alors ils peuvent se rendre sur le site
du rnj a donc et le réseau national des
juniors associations
donc c'est junior association point org
donc le tout au singulier dessus ils
vont avoir toute une série de documents
qui vont leur permettre de découvrir un
peu mieux le dispositif s ils ont des
questions ils peuvent nous écrire donc
que ce soit à nous ou à la ligue de
l'enseignement nous on a une adresse est
assez simple cj points à sow @ usine à
chapeaux point fr donc le tout sans
accent il nous envoie un petit mail et
puis nous on pourra répondre à leurs
questions ou les réorienter vers les
personnes qui pourront répondre à leurs
questions évidemment ils peuvent aussi
retrouver le facebook live en replay sur
la page du foyer de lusine de l'usiné à
chapeaux et là ils auront normalement
une description beaucoup plus détaillée
de ce qu'est le dispositif et de ce
qu'ils peuvent faire avec une junior
association
merci en tout cas tous les deux nous
avoir présenté ce dispositif
merci à vous et merci à vous aurez lire
et puis un mot de religion pour refermer
ce journal le ramadan débutera ce
vendredi pour les cent quarante mille
yvelinois de confession musulmane
de partage de prière dans un contexte
forcément particulier qui est celui du
confinement est les mosquées comme tous
les lieux de culte sont fermés
actuellement et ce jusqu'au moins est la
mi juin écouter le président du cam 78
et le collectif des associations
musulmanes de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les propos sont recueillis par wilfrid
richy parce que pendant le ramadan il ya
un principe des repas de rupture du
jeûne qui était quelque chose de très
important dans la tradition dans
l'esprit le les notions de partage et de
générosité lors des opérations de
distribution de boxe de pâques et des
iftars boxe que les personnes viendront
chercher avant l'heure de rupture du
jeûne et qu'elles récupéreront pour
manger à la maison
seul et puis il ya aussi des opérations
de distribution dans des zones où il ya
des concentrations de personnes un petit
peu dans des situations précaires et
vulnérable ce sont les foyers de
travailleurs isolés et là il y aura des
distributions avec certaines
associations du cam en partenariat avec
d'autres associations humanitaires
locales
un des dessins de l'islam de la
législation islamique c'est la
préservation de la vie humaine la
préservation de la vie humaine passe
avant tout et avant certaines choses qui
paraissent obligatoire qui sont
obligatoires qui sont préférables comme
les prières collectives qui sont
obligatoires certes mais la préservation
de la vie humaine passe avant cela et
c'est pour cela que nous avions fermé la
mosquée avant le début du confinement et
c'est pour ça que les mosquées resteront
fermées pendant le mois du ramadan et je
profite de cette audience pour rappeler
à tous les musulmans qui écouteront cela
que c'est vrai qu'avec les beaux jours
on peut considérer qu'on sort plus
facilement mais non il faut faire
attention pour rester confiné il faut
faire attention parce qu'on peut être un
vecteur aussi de mal pour ses proches et
pour la société en général
donc profitons en pour faire une
introspection pour peut-être plus lire
le coran
le mouvement du ramadan est le mois de
la lecture du coran peut être revoir nos
pratiques religieuses mais en tout cas
pas de pratique collective
et pendant ce ramadan le cam 78
proposera également des vidéos pour les
fidèles via les réseaux sociaux
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité le
replay disponible sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
restez chez vous et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]